first of all it's a great privilege to
be here to be invited by you people this
invitation
all this vita because my daughter
actually is in the class of 2006 you
know this is an opportunity for me to
look a little bit smarter in front of
her because as you all know no man is a
hero to his children throughout my talk
I will use the term he to mean both
genders so kindly understand that I am
not biased if I use the term he I will
speak today on the lessons that I have
learned as the CEO of the company for
the first 21 years even today I am the
executive chairman of the company in
other words so whatever I speak is the
hopefully the digital wisdom of my
experience of running this company for
the last 25 years or so these lessons
will be in general true for almost any
corporation hence I will avoid taking
any example specific to emphasis a
little bit about emphasis for us it was
founded in 1981 as Dean jaws said by me
and six of the software professionals
the mainframe monopoly had just ended or
broken with robust online transaction
processing available on super mini
computers running multics kind of
operating system the PC revolution had
just started with word processors and
spreadsheet being available on
inexpensive computers Borland was about
to launch the words first sub
hundred-dollar software therefore we
knew then that demand for software
applications would explode and there
will be opportunity for a company
specializing in customized software
development from a country like India
there was indeed another evolution suit
in the
world and that is globalization i define
globalization as sourcing capital from
where it is cheapest sourcing talent
from where it is best available
producing where it is most
cost-effective and selling where the
market saw I would like to say that it
is most profitable without being
constrained by national boundaries it
was very clear that those nourished
those nations which had certain
competitive advantage would be able to
offer value in this global bazaar in
this era of globalization we knew India
had a clear competitive advantage in
customized software development because
of the availability of large number of
english-speaking technical talent that's
how in Phasis was started
however as dean jose pointed out in the
first 10 years our growth was inhibited
by excessive friction to business in
india it all changed thanks to the
economic reforms of 1991 let me give
some data on emphasis of today last year
we closed the year at two point one five
billion dollars a net income of 550 plus
million dollars and today we have a
market capitalisation of approximately
twenty billion dollars banking and
capital markets retail and high-tech
manufacturing or the major areas of our
specialization we operate in 38
countries and we have development
centers in seven countries including the
United States the company has grown at
40 plus percentage during the last ten
years we were listed in India in 1993
and we got listed on NASDAQ in 1999 I am
glad to say we have not missed a single
quarter since we got listed the company
has been recognized for its leadership
in innovation in employee orientation
and corporate governance the major
innovations of emphasis are many but I
will talk only about so the first is the
24 hour productive day which combines
the prime
of customers in the US with our
primetime thereby providing a 24 hour
workday for customers and compressing
cycle time for them the second is the
global delivery model basically the
global delivery model splits a large
software development task into two
groups the first set of tasks have high
interaction with our customers
activities like requirement definition
installation of software and Rapid
Reaction warranty
requires that we opt that we be present
at customer side all the other hand
activities like programming design you
know documentation long-term warranty
can be taken up from talent rich
process-driven
scalable and cost competitive
development centers in countries like
India with such a model customer gets
best value for money and of course we
provide the customer with quality
software on time within budget it calls
to me the view from the top is shaped
your large extent by how people really
der from the bottom in some sense in
fact seriously because in fact a leader
success is defined by how well he or she
can synthesize
the bird's eye view of the world with
the worm's eye view of the world success
to me is about taking great ideas and
converting them to action through
excellence I'm convinced that the
primary resource of the corporation is
its people hence I will first talk about
people and then about other issues the
primary job of a leader is bringing
about team or bringing about
transformation transformation as you all
know is big-ticket progress progress is
all about change transformation comes
about because of transformation of the
mindset of the people we all have two
instruments for progress and the first
to the mind and the second is the
mindset to me mind is the analytical
engine that uses data to take
appropriate decisions on the other hand
mindset you the set of distant
conclusions that we have gathered from
our
experience over the years mind is what
determines our aspirations our
confidence our possibilities and in
short our behavior the task of a leader
therefore is to change the mindset of
people to become positive to become
confident to become enthusiastic daring
and open-minded to accept change to
accept you know great great great dreams
a leader does it by us by raising the
aspirations of his people in my opinion
aspiration is the main fuel for progress
aspirations help people overcome
tremendous odds by working hard and
smart making personal sacrifices and
putting the interest of the corporation
I had of one's own aspirations help
people embrace the adage a plausible
impossibility is better than a
convincing possibility in 1981 when we
were just seven people and had revenues
of one hundred and thirty thousand
dollars we set out to become the most
respected cooperation among six thousand
five hundred plus listed companies in
India it seemed at that time odorous but
it has happened today because of our
aspirations most progress
I believe gets hampered because there
are many naysayers in the corporation
whenever you propose something dramatic
you're not short of people will come to
you and say don't you know our context
it is not possible here
therefore a leader has to overcome the
the the naysayers pessimism and make
sure they give it a try most people see
the context is a constraint but leaders
must see them as opportunity this is
where I'm often reminded of what George
Bernard Shaw said and what was adopted
by Robert Kennedy from George Bernard
Shaw and and he said I caught him most
people see things as they are and wonder
why a dream of things that never were
and say why not and go any progress
I believe requires smartness some you
know lots of hard work and of course
sacrifice to get people to make the
sacrifices needed in
leader has to become credible and
trustworthy credibility I believe is way
through leadership by example people
watch a leader avidly and imitate him
every attribute of a corporation is
exemplified by its leader
therefore in everything we do whether
its cost control or excellence of
customer focus the leaders at Infosys
demonstrate their commitment to the
cause
no wonder Mothma Gandhi once said and I
quote him be the change you want to see
in the world therefore a leader uses his
value system to instill trust in other
people I have realized that there are
only two things that make you more and
more India enduring in the marketplace
and they are being relevant to your
customer and number two making greater
and greater impact